and we've now reached one of the most
famous churches in germany the saint
thomas church in leipzig known mostly
because none other than the great
musician and composer johann sebastian
bachma's choir master here in the 18th
century but bach was not a native of
leipzig unlike the gentleman who's
standing right next to me we've already
seen him end the report peter freibur
simon and i have to also mention that
you grew up in east germany and english
was not part of your school curriculum
but nevertheless thank you so much for
speaking in english with us now and
allowing us to find out a bit more about
what happened 25 years ago you're
currently preparing the 1 000 year
anniversary of leipzig which takes place
next year 1 000 years what significance
does the fall of the berlin wall 25
years ago have in this context
in a historical view it's only a smart
part but for the people they live now
are 25 years
important part of her life it really
matters and obviously i mean
it was quite dramatic what happened back
then i watched it on television in
western germany
so
i can only imagine how
dramatic and worrying it must have been
to go to the streets under the communist
system and demand freedom
you were there were you ever worried
that things could go wrong
yes we had fear in this time uh also we
have seen uh some months before in china
square
and
but
you see also 70 000 people or
demonstrate every monday
and this is a very strong uh an
impressive
situation for you and you will remember
every time this this days yeah i must
have been very empowering
70 000 people and of course it also
spread to other cities but i keep
wondering why did it happen in 1989 the
communist germany existed for 40 years
more than 40 years and suddenly people
say now it's time to change things why
we have enough food it's not an economic
problem at first
but
the people are
want to have more
press freedom they want elections free
elections and they want another
political system
would you do it again in hindsight
looking back was it the right decision
yes it's what it was the right decision
if you see now this beautiful town and
if you
feel how grow up uh this city and this
part of germany
it was the right it was the right
decision
thank you very much and best of luck for
your 1000 year anniversary next year
thank you very much